hier in den wäldern im bosnischen be hat
an der grenze zur eu entscheidet sich
das schicksal vieler geflüchteter aus
krisengebieten und elends staaten ziel
europa wollen sie über die balkanroute
erreichen
so wie familie rasuli in dieser ruine
macht die familie aus afghanistan rast
nach einem jahr auf der flucht über den
iran und die türkei sitzen sie nun in
der bosnischen grenzstadt mihatsch fest
heute wollen sie es über die kroatische
grenze schaffen letzte vorbereitungen
für den weg in ein hoffentlich besseres
leben ich habe eine jacke eingepackt
noch einen schlafsack für das baby denn
es ist sehr kalt noch ein paar schuhe
für das baby und jetzt kann es lust von
zehn mal hat es die familie über die
bosnische grenze richtung eu versucht
bisher ohne erfolg
jedes mal wurden sie von der kroatischen
polizei wieder zurückgedrängt doch die
hoffnung dass es irgendwann klappen
könnte geben sie nicht auf ich habe
angst vor der polizei
es ist jedes mal sehr schwer für mich
ich habe nur meine tasche dabei und ich
weiß nicht ob sie mir wieder alles
abnehmen werden
es ist sieben uhr früh im morgengrauen
bricht die kleine gruppe flüchtlinge bei
temperaturen von minus vier grad auf ein
dreistündiger fußmarsch durch die
eiseskälte steht der zwölfköpfigen
familie aus afghanistan bevor wenn das
gelobte land europa zu kommen
von kroatien über slowenien nach
deutschland da wollen wir hin
aber ich weiß nicht ob wir es schaffen
das bosnische die hat liegt an der
eu-außengrenze von hier sind es nur
wenige kilometer nach kroatien
doch das land ist nur eine art
transitzone für die geflüchteten von
hier aus wollen die migranten weiter in
ihre sehnsuchtsorte deutschland
frankreich und italien
doch die hadsch ist für viele eine
sackgasse junge männer aus bangladesch
die es nicht über die grenze geschafft
haben müssen in diesen wilden camps
ausharren in provisorischen zelten
gebaut aus alten planen und testen die
sie im wald gefunden haben
einer dieser jungen männer zeigt uns
seine notunterkunft seit fünf wochen
wurden hier schlafe ich habe ein wenig
kleidung einen schlafsack ein bisschen
essen hier schlafen wir zu viert denn es
ist sonst viel zu kalt schneit nach das
problem die offiziellen einrichtungen
sind jetzt schon überfüllt und können
niemanden mehr aufnehmen
die bosnische regierung schätzt dass
knapp 2000 geflüchtete unter diesen
miserablen bedingungen in den wäldern
leben hier kochen wir gerne reis oder
curry von dem was gespendet wird das
essen wir dann hier eigentlich schlafen
sie in den welt an tagsüber um für die
nächtlichen fluchtversuche fit zu sein
in den wintermonaten bei
durchschnittlich minus acht grad in der
nacht haben die migranten aus
bangladesch ihrem routenplan ins eu
nachbarland kroatien auf den tag verlegt
ich will nach italien frankreich oder
spanien um mich niederzulassen
denn in meinem land ist das ein großes
problem bosnien und herzegowina lag
abseits der balkanroute doch seit 2000
17 versuchen zehntausende von dort aus
in die eu zu gelangen
ihren weg zur kroatischen grenze nennen
die migranten nur hoffnungsvoll begann
auf dem spiel steht dabei ihr leben
seitdem die kroatische polizei keine
flüchtlinge mehr durchlässt versuchen es
viele illegal über die landesgrenzen
vergebens die meisten von ihnen werden
auf ihrer route aufgegriffen und werden
nach bosnien und herzegowina wieder
abgeschoben
es ist ein ewiges räuber und gendarm
spiel zwischen der kroatischen
staatsmacht und den geflüchteten die
kroatische polizei hat mich schon
dreimal gefangen genommen und geschlagen
bis auf die unterhose haben sie mir
alles weggenommen
sie haben mir mein handy abgenommen das
war das erste wonach sie gefragt habe
der verdacht kroatische grenzpolizisten
stoppen gewaltsam die fluchtversuche der
migranten heimlich gefilmte
videoaufnahmen der
menschenrechtsorganisation border
violence monitoring dokumentieren die
rückführung der flüchtlinge
die so genannten push back laut genfer
konventionen und eu recht ist das aber
verboten und dann enden die geflüchteten
wieder da wo sie begonnen haben
zurück in der sackgasse bosnien nicht
selten soll es auch zum brutalen
misshandlungen seitens der kroatischen
polizei gekommen sein
auf dem video zu sehen ein flüchtling
abgekämpft und verletzt die kroatischen
behörden weisen diese vorwürfe aber
zurück die grausamkeit der kroatischen
grenzpolizei dokumentiert in einem
weiteren foto erst im oktober wird das
bild eines gefolterten flüchtlings in
den sozialen medien geteilt der rücken
des jungen mannes übersät von offenen
wunden
wir finden den man vom foto im
flüchtlingscamp miral sein name mohsen
campari als der 24 jährige afghane
versucht im oktober über die grenze zu
kommen wird er von der kroatischen
polizei aufgegriffen und brutal
misshandelt
die kroatische polizei hat mich
aufgegriffen und dann mit aufs revier
genommen
dort muss sich zwei nächte bleiben sie
haben mir meine kleidung mitgenommen
ich war komplett nackt auch das handy um
mein letztes geld haben sie mir
abgenommen
dann haben sie mich 15 minuten
ausgepeitscht und mich mit einem knüppel
verprügelt die bunten des 24 jährigen
sind mittlerweile wieder verheilt drei
wochen lang konnte der afghanen nicht
auf dem rücken liegen die schmerzen
waren zu groß
und trotzdem nach allen strapazen will
er es noch einmal versuchen
ich will nächste woche wieder los über
die grenze ich habe doch keine andere
wahl
es macht keinen sinn hier zu bleiben
nach allem was war muss ich es trotzdem
weiter versuchen
ich habe mein land doch aus guten grund
verlassen und bin hergekommen
ich will endlich in europa ankommen
diese fälle von kroatischer grenz gewalt
sind der bosnischen polizei nicht
unbekannt rechtlich sind ihnen jedoch
die hände gebunden
in vielen fällen sollen die migranten
von personen in uniform und maske
angegriffen worden sei so sagen sie es
uns
wir leiten die aussagen der migranten
dann an das innenministerium oder an das
ministerium für sicherheit
mehr können wir nicht tun wir können
nicht nach kroatien gehen und dort
nachforschungen anstellen
die grenzpolizei sollte sich da mal mehr
informiert
da sollten sie die kroatische polizei
mal in frage
nirgendwo dokumentiert sich das
scheitern der europäischen
migrationspolitik so sehr wie in bi hat
irgendwo zwischen verzweiflung und
hoffnung treffen wir auch familie rasuli
wieder seit mehreren stunden marschiert
die familie nun durch die eiseskälte in
eine bessere zukunft
wir brauchen noch circa eineinhalb
stunden bis zur grenze wir gehen durch
den wald dann liegen wir in einen
kleinen weg ab und dann sind wir in
kroatien
es ist versuch nummer elf der weg in die
freiheit er ist kalt und hart wir werden
die zwölfköpfige familie wiedersehen
unterwegs mit förster vordruck erkennt
die schmuggelrouten die in seoul an
kroatien führen nur zu gut
das ist die strecke von bier hat nach
kroatien
das ist hier naturschutzgebiet die
migranten eben auf diese rote und
hinterlassen hier ihren müll stadt
bekommen kultur herrscht bei ford
mittlerweile nur noch gut hier schaut
man ihren ganzen müll haben sie hier
gelassen
sie wandern hoch in die berge und
hinterlassen müll wie man sehen kann
das macht mich so hier haben sie
geschlafen wie man sieht schaut euch das
an
irgendwer muss den dreck ja wieder weg
räumen was nie weg geräumt wurde sind
noch die überbleibsel aus dem
jugoslawienkrieg der 90er jahre auf der
strecke in richtung grenze sind die
wälder noch voller minen todesfälle
durch die mienen gab es in den letzten
zehn jahren aber keine hier die schilder
warnen vor dem ihn aus den kriegsjahren
91 bis 94
hier ist es auch eigentlich verboten
entlang zu laufen
es ist extrem gefährlich aber die
migranten scheint es nicht zu stören
oder sie haben einfach keine angst sie
wandern hier die berge hoch in richtung
kroatien zurück im tal für die migranten
für die es im leben immer weiter bergab
geht gibt es hilfe von der eu
der internationalen organisation für
migration vorbereitungen für den
heutigen tag
der transporter des mobilen teams wird
beladen für jeden geflüchteten stellen
die helfer eine 2 tagesration mit
konserven tütensuppen und auch brot
bereit
so hier drin haben wir eigentlich alles
notwendige unterhosen unterhemden socken
ein handtuch ein normales t shirt und
dann noch hygiene-artikel eine
zahnbürste zahncreme shampoo und rasier
geht der transporter des teams er ist
vollgepackt zurückkommen wird er war
leer
es geht los in richtung bosnische wälder
hier warten schon etwa 50 junge männer
aus afghanistan und bangladesh
ausgehungert und durchgefroren auf essen
und warme kleidung sogar corona konform
waren sie eine leine und eine meter
distanz corona und den menschen hier
fehlt es an allem vor allem feste schuhe
für den winter sind mangelware
sie alle sind obdachlos leben in den
wäldern und besitzen nur noch das was
sie am leib tragen ihr gespartes geld
für die flucht haben sie schon lange
nicht mehr
ich habe einen schlafsack bekommen ich
wohne dahin im wald
zumindest werden die winternächte in den
wäldern für den jungen mann nun etwas
wärmer werden
hinter der eu grenze liegt für die
geflüchteten das gelobte land europa für
viele bleibt dieser ort jedoch ein traum
der nächste tag zurück auf polnischer
seite der push back der kroatischen
grenzpolizei hat familie rasuli in ihre
beton ruine getrieben wieder in den
dreck und wieder in die kälte
der elfte fluchtversuch er ist
gescheitert
[Musik]
nach 22 minuten auf der anderen seite
wurden wir schon wieder von den kroaten
aufgegriffen und abgewiesen
sie haben mir gestern das handy
abgenommen und auch meine schuhe haben
sie genommen
und so sitzt die zwölfköpfige familie
wieder am lagerfeuer kräfte sammeln für
den nächsten flucht versucht dann mit
familienmitglied nummer 13
sie ist im achten monat schwanger und
will das kind am liebsten in deutschland
bekommen
morgen wollen ist der zehnjährige faizal
rasuli und sein kleiner bruder wieder
über die grenze versuchen es ist
fluchtversuch nummer 12 dass sie es
schaffen ist unwahrscheinlich
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren